este circuito combina lo mejor de ambos
mundos con este circuito nuestro robot
tendrá la capacidad de ir hacia adelante
y hacia atrás porque agregamos algo
llamado un interruptor de palanca de un
polo y doble tiro y es llamado
interruptor de palanca porque tiene esta
pequeña palanca tiene un polo y tiene
dos tiros esos son los términos usados
para estos contactos eléctricos
entonces si encendemos el interruptor y
dejamos que fluya la corriente eléctrica
vemos que el motor empieza a girar el
motor gira en una dirección y si
queremos que gire en la otra dirección
presionamos esta palanca y puedes ver
que hace que el motor gire en la
dirección opuesta lo que está sucediendo
aquí es que el contacto dentro de ese
interruptor cambia del cable rojo que es
el cable positivo al cable negro que es
el cable negativo eso hace que la
corriente eléctrica fluye en la
dirección contraria
y como hace eso bueno lo hace porque la
corriente pasa por una pila a la vez
pasa por esta pila en esta dirección y
cuando empujamos la palanca del
interruptor la corriente eléctrica choca
y corre en reversa dentro de la otra
pila eso hace que el motor cambie de una
dirección a otra y ahora si tomamos este
circuito y lo combinamos con otro
interruptor y otro motor podremos hacer
que nuestro robot pueda cambiar de
dirección
y bueno aquí está la combinación de
todos los circuitos de los que te hablé
tenemos aquí las luces y el circuito con
el interruptor que enciende las luces es
este interruptor se encienden las luces
cuando enciendo el interruptor
y también tenemos el circuito para el
motor tenemos los interruptores de
palanca con un polo y doble tiro y aquí
tenemos un ejemplo de cómo se ve por
dentro un interruptor de palanca con un
polo y doble tiro observa también que
extendimos los interruptores poniendo
estas antenas que están hechas de
eclipses doblados que pegué con silicón
y las antenas al chocar contra la pared
empujan la palanca del interruptor con
mayor facilidad y también actúan como
amortiguadores para no aplicar tanta
fuerza sobre la palanca ahora encendamos
esto puedes ver que gira hacia adelante
es decir mover al robot en esa dirección
hacia el frente y si el robot choca
digamos de este lado al chocar esta
antena la antena presionar a la palanca
este interruptor y hará que este motor
cambie de dirección y si éste está
antena que choca entonces este motor
cambiará de dirección entonces te
recuerdo lo que la interruptor hace es
cambiar la dirección de la corriente
eléctrica que pasa por una de las pilas
por una de las pilas la corriente
eléctrica va en una dirección después
cambia a la otra que va en la otra
dirección lo cual hace que el motor gire
en la dirección contraria y así el robot
pueda retroceder ahora en caso de que
ambas antenas choquen eso hará que ambos
motores giren hacia atrás haciendo que
el robot retroceda
y eso explica lo que está ocurriendo
dentro del robot